c'est le 21 mars 2006 qui est posté le
tout premier tweet qu'on va voir vous
allez voir il a assez minimaliste avec
je viens de configurer mon tweet vous le
voyez ici c'est l'un des quatre
fondateurs qu'il a fondée et bien
l'année dernière ce petit message vous
savez à combien il a été estimée est
vendu avant on n'avait ni annonce qui
suit là d'une nouvelle trouvaille a donc
près de 3 millions de dollars et non
sous forme de nfc il a été vendu
mélanges de motifs et de couleurs
aujourd'hui les chaussettes dépareillées
sont de sortie ce lundi 21 mars c'est la
journée mondiale de la trisomie 21 et ce
petit geste symbolique permet de
valoriser la différence dans l'espoir
d'une société plus inclusive sur les
réseaux sociaux l'initiative soutenue
par de nombreuses associations est très
suivi vous vous en êtes fait
quelques-uns de lucchini ah ah oui vous
ne sais pas ce que c'est les ont cédé 11
rien d'autre à dire son dégoût sont des
points ce sont des voix la voyez ce
match pas mes mots encore ni son éponge
je vous dis ça m'arrive d'être moi et ça
m'est arrivé peut-être plusieurs plus
plus de fois qu aux autres mais ce sont
des bons parce que il saute sur
l'occasion de la pandémie l'un pour dire
mais l'autre il le restera tories lab
les couteaux mais ferme ta gueule
rien
c'était c'est le problème quand on
discute parfois pendant les reportages
après le frère monte bon il y avait que
les avions où il y avait un avion et un
logement ou quelque chose comme ça mais
alors qu hervé pouchol au moment où je
vous parle bien de se renverser du café
il a bu comme un porc et il a pas de
choses parce que je l' ai dans mon écran
de contrôle général gilbert il s'en est
mis plein la vue de tout renverser dont
je prend son sac à langer et tu te
débrouilles pour le reste oui j'ai mis
les lourdes qui croyez pas que le petit
[Musique]
attends tu commences mais de la journée
un ferme la et puis donne ce que tu as à
donner ne vient pas nous donner tes
était peut-être au prurit
cérébrale les kinés bigard c'est vrai
pardon on est des acteurs on est au
service du public et on est là pour leur
apprendre la joie et leur offrir quelque
chose on n'est pas là pour se montrer en
dix ans mais le gouvernement on s'en
fout et kras toile gouvernement tiller
au gouvernement tu la veux la place donc
ça ça m'insupporte dans un entretien
accordée à closer la candidate
socialiste anne hidalgo s'est exprimé
sur sa différence d'âge de 7 ans avec
son mari alors je ne me sens pas tout
car contrairement à d'autres je n'aurais
jamais pu tomber amoureuse d'un
adolescent un tacle directement adressée
à emmanuel macron et sa femme brigitte
qui ont quant à elles 24 ans tu
différence il serait temps d'évoluer un
peu
ok ce sont des égocentriques nombrilique
mégalo je ne sais pas quoi mais
franchement il donne une image de ce
métier
épouvantable alors que moi la chance que
j'ai c'est que je connais les grands
artistes du théâtre et du cinéma je les
connais je les fréquente et j'essaye
d'apporter mon tout petit pierre à
l'édifice donc le film soit réussie et
non pas montrer ma gueule en disant vous
avez vu vous avez vu